-Did you know that Clementine
was my grandfather's?
-Yeah.
-He named it
after his mother.
Oh, boy.
He was a very strict man.
But I always
found him reasonable.
♪♪
And he had a policy.
He would only kill
if it was absolutely necessary.
[ Gun cocks ]
For food...
or to vanquish an enemy...
or to eliminate
an incompetent imbecile.
-Mistakes were made.
It won't happen again.
-Oh, I know it won't.
-Oh!
[ Laughs ]
-That's a real dramatic --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Real dramatic clip.
-[ Laughs ]
-We're back of Bryan Cranston.
That was a clip from "Argylle."
A great cast.
Rob Delaney was in that clip.
-Yeah.
-Another great comedian actor.
-Yeah, very funny.
-Dua Lipa -- my good friend
Dua Lipa was in the film.
-I heard and saw that --
that clip of you.
-Yeah.
-You were imbibing a little bit.
-We imbibed.
-You were imbibing.
-Now you did not have
a scene with Dua,
so you don't know
that she's a bully.
-Is she really?
-Yeah.
She bullied me into
getting my first tattoo.
-Through what? What was her --
her way into bullying you?
-She is Dua Lipa, and she asked.
[ Laughter ]
-That -- That is.
-That's horrible of her.
-That's horrible!
-Horrible.
-What else was I gonna say?
-Yes.
-Now, you got a tattoo
with Aaron Paul.
Matching tattoo.
-Yeah. Well, they're not
matching tattoos.
-Okay, gotcha.
-The last day of production,
11 years ago,
I got a tattoo on my hand,
but you can't see it.
-Okay.
-Because, an actor,
I don't want to have it social.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But I did get it right there.
-Wow. Very good.
There's --
Yeah, the "BB." There you go.
-It's the symbol
for "Breaking Bad."
And someone said,
"Why put it there?"
No one else can see it.
And I said,
"Well, it's not really
for someone else, it's for me."
And when I catch it, I remember
the times that we had
on this wonderful show.
-Do you want to see
my matching tattoo?
-I do.
I want to see your tattoo.
-Okay.
Here we go. Ready?
-Yeah.
You guys got it over there?
Okay. Here we go.
Here we go.
-Ah!
Very nice!
[ Applause ]
-There we go.
Her call, not mine.
-Very nice.
Yeah.
-No, actually, here's, uh --
here's the real one right there.
It's that.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I thi--
I think that's just a mole.
-Yeah, well, guess what.
John Oliver,
who's a very cruel person,
he said
it looks like a tick.
-Yeah, yeah!
[ Laughter ]
So that's like --
the rest of every summer,
the rest of my life,
my wife's gonna be like,
"Check for ticks," and I'm like,
"It's not a tick."
-Now, it's kind of
a personal thing.
-Yeah.
-So, a very attractive
young woman...
-Yeah.
-...convinces you to get
a matching tattoo?
-Yeah.
-What did your wife
say about that?
-We -- You know what?
It's funny. We're trying
not to talk about it.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I won't bring it up.
I'm sorry I brought it up.
-I mean, I feel like
we talk about it,
like, non-verbally,
with a lot of sighs.
-Yeah and looks and side eye.
-A lot of looks
and a lot of sighs.
Now, of course, mine is a --
is a temporary tattoo.
But a lot of people
did get Heisenberg tattoos.
-Oh, God, yeah.
-And you've gotten to learn
over the years.
I mean, these are intense.
-Yeah, that's on an arm.
-That's on an arm.
-Got the RV and everything.
That's on a neck.
-That's a neck.
-Yeah.
-He's, like, pulling down --
-This is a fun one.
Just on the back of a head.
-Yeah.
He carved it out on his head.
And then this one -- this is --
Well, I mean,
that's just a human butt.
-That's, uh...
[ Laughter ]
That's on a butt.
Now, if you look closely
to this,
uh, on the left, you see Larry,
and Moe is down below.
So I'm actually the third Stooge
on someone's ass.
-I just like -- there's some
lady out there who loves
"Breaking Bad" and the Stooges
and saw this guy's butt,
and is like, "He's a keeper."
-"He's a Stooge."
-"He's the guy."
-Actually, they must have
thought I was Curly.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, he's bald.
That's Curly."
-Uh, you got to work
in the film
not only with great actors,
but there's a cat named Alfie.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
Yeah.
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
It did not go well?
-I hate that cat.
[ Laughter ]
That cat thinks he's
"Oh, big show business" now.
He's stealing every scene.
-He --
-You know what?
He walks down the hall.
You're not supposed to look him
directly in the eye.
I mean, it's like
you're supposed to...
He's got his agents following
him around and everything.
-I mean, I will say
that's problematic
because even unfamous
cats are ass [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
So they're all starting
at a place of the worst.
-They're the worst,
and they get even worse.
Yes.
-Was Alfie the name --
Uh, that's the cat's name.
-Well, the name of the real
cat...
-Okay.
-...is Chip.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-And Chip is, um...
owned by a supermodel.
-Yeah.
-Isn't that the --
-So. there's Claudia Schiffer
right there.
-Yes.
-And that's -- so Chip the cat
actually gets carried
around in this case.
-Yes. Carried around.
I would like to be carried
around in a case like that.
And, in fact,
by Claudia Schiffer,
I would like to crawl in --
Okay.
Um, actually,
and that's where, you know,
they talked about,
uh, the Taylor Swift.
There was rumor that
Taylor Swift wrote "Argylle."
And while I cannot deny
or confirm that, apparently,
Taylor Swift has a cat in a --
in a cat carrier like that,
and so they thought
there was a tie-in to it.
-Gotcha.
Now, this must have been
the hardest
acting you've ever done.
You had to actually act
and hold the same case.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. Um...
-Yeah.
-And I'm --
I'm allergic to cats.
-Yeah.
-Well, I'm mostly allergic
to the musical "Cats," but...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people --
That's one
of the more common allergies.
-Yeah, but also
the actual feline.
-Yeah.
-It makes my eyes water.
Um, yeah, I -- my character
doesn't like cats,
and so he mistreated
the fake cat.
We had a real cat
and fake cat.
Chip was not only treated
like a star, that he is --
he was on the phone during
the breaks calling Scorsese.
And, you know, it's like,
"Uh, what's next for me?"
-And on speaker, right?
So you could all hear.
-On speaker!
So we're like...
-"We know --
you got connections, Chip."
-So classless.
-Well, again, it speaks to you
as an actor
that I've only heard
great things
about how you interacted
with Chip, who you clearly hate.
-I clearly hate him.
Yeah.
But, you know,
he is the star of this movie.
-Yeah.
-Which I am, uh, very sad about.
[ Laughter ]
-The movie is fun, however.
-The movie is fun.
-Oh, my God, it's so much fun.
-And thanks for being here.
It's always so much fun
to see you.
Always such a pleasure.
You guys, Bryan Cranston.
"Argylle," theaters and IMAX,
February 2nd.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Lola Tung.